- Cargo 200. En Russe,
"Gruz dvésti" : c'est le nom
que les Soviétiques ont do
au ramassage des morts en
Afghanistan dans les années 80.
aussi.
Le nombre 200 est inscrit
sur le camion. 200 kilos,
dans un cercueil en zinc.
Avec le chien qui portiiii
le 200, Laryssa Boryssenko,
de l'ONG Antares, se consacre
ukrainiens morts avec l'unité
spécialisée de l'armée
ukrainienne.
"Il est très importanterererert
tous droit à une sépulture
correcte. Ces soldats morts,
combien sont-ils dans cette
XAVIER TYTELMAN, consultant en
aéronautique, Air & Cosmos
- Du côté des militaires,
c'est très compliqué d'avoir
évidemment, les chiffres sont
cachés et aucun des deux
protagonistes ne communique
très clairement.
- Depuis toujours, secret
Tytelman se base sur des données
précises et documentées,
comme celles du site Oryx.
- On sait que les Russes ont
perdu quasiment 80 y y y y y y a
peut-être 10 000 qui ont été
perdus. Mais on a les photos
de quasiment 8000 véhicules
Or, traditionnellement,
on sait qu'il y a entre six et
huit morts par véhicule perdu.
60 et 80 000 soldats russes qui
seraient morts sur le terrain,
plus tous les blessés qui sont
- Les chiffres officiels
plus de 85 000 morts russes,
probablement exagérés. Autre
repaire, le nombre d'officiers
- Si bien qu'on a plus de 1500
officiers russes qui ont été
identifiés. Et on a généralement
de 30. Donc c'est-à-dire que,
pour un officier, vous avez
30 soldats du rang. Ce qui fait,
à peu près encore une fois,
45 000. Et là, ce n'est que
le ratio par rapport
Donc certainement que le chiffre
de 60 000 est tout à fait
crédible.
aucun chiffre et les Ukrainiens
ne disent rien de leurs pertes.
- Du côté ukrainien, on a
bizarrement moins précises,
notamment parce qu'ils ont perdu
beaucoup moins de matériel.
de l'invasion, les Ukrainiens
étaient moins armés, donc
il y a moins d'équipements.ionn,
une armée qui fait
des offensives ratées, et c'est
ce que la Russie a fait pendante
pertes que le défenseur. Donc,
logiquement, on estime qu'il y
aurait entre 45 000, 50 000ldldt
morts depuis le début.
civiles, tous Ukrainiennes,
bien sûr, les Nations unies
les estiment à près de 7000,
dont prèIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIt
davantage, avec en plus
presque 8 millions de réfugiés
un peu partout en Europe.
Les Russes ont perdu en 9
au moins trois fois plus
de soldats qu'en Afghanistan
qui a mal fini pour Moscou.
La grande question
pour l'Ukraine, quel est le
seuil de toléranceememememlin...
et du peuple russe?
Jean-Michel Leprinc